موقع اوكرانيا اليوم الاخباريه محمد
العروقي اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه ما ابعاد هذه
القضايا قضى الفساد هل هي جزء مما يحدث ام
ان هناك او يعني كما يقال ما خفي كان اكبر
بكثير هل هناك قضايا اخرى ربما لم تخرج
حتى الان الى العالم ولكن معروف عن هذه
الدوائر كثره فضائح فضائح الفساد
تحياتي لكم يعني حقيقه
الفساد عالميه ولكنه يعني ملفت النظر في
اوكرانيا وهي يعني قصه بلا نهايه يعني
الفساد في اوكرانيا هو يعني من احد يعني
ما خلفه الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق فبالتالي
نجد ان مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا يعني
قضيه تحتاج الى سنين وسنين انها ثقافه يجب
زرعها الجديد الذي يتم تعليمه على
الشفافيه والتفاني في العمل فبالتالي يعني
ما حدث في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قد لا
يكون الاتهام مباشره مباشره الى الوزنكوب
وزير الدفاع ولكن مما يحدث وكاله وزاره
الدفاع حقيقه اذا اعتقدنا انه كانت تحارب
على الجبهه معروفه فهذا مفهوم خاطئ هناك
ايضا يعني مواجهه داخليه هي في اوكرانيا
وهي محاربه الفساد يقوم بها منذ تعينه
رئيسا لاوكرانيا في عام 2019 يعني وجدنا
في وزاره الدفاع قبل فتره يعني قال برسائل
شعب التجنيد وجدنا هناك يعني تغييرات في
حكام المناطق وجدنا تناقلات بين العسكريين
فبالتالي هذه يعني مواجهه داخليه سوف تؤثر
على المعركه مع روسيا على الحدود او على
المعركه العسكريه يعني هذه القضايا وغيرها
من فضائح الفساد تعرقل عمل او ما يسمى
بالهجوم المضاده لاي مدى تؤثر في حسن
السير العمليات يعني بغض النظر عن المضاد
بمعنى عامر هم الفساد هو يرفر في اي دوله
ويؤثر على على مقوماتها وتؤثر على
مواجهتها فبالتالي نعتقد ان ان موضوع
الفساد اوكرانيا تواجهه في اوقات صعبه
ولكن
الاوكرانيه انه لا مناصب من مواجهه هذا
الفساد وخاصه في الاوقات الحاليه التي
تعيشها اوكرانيا فبالتالي اعتقد ان وزير
الدفاع كان ضحيه لموضوع هذا الفساد اكثر
منه يعني ان يكون متهما لانه كان احد
اعمده هذه الدوله وسيبقى اعتقد انه قد
ينتقل الى الى الى منصب اخر وقد يتم سفيرا
في بريطانيا كما قرانا حسب وسائل الاعلام
فبالتالي اعتقد ان يعني هذا ما حدث اما
بالنسبه يعني للتعيين وزير الدفاع الجديد
الا وهو هذه لها عده رسائل وعده ابعاد كما
قال الرئيس في ضغط دماء جديده
لماذا ابعاد تعيين شخصيه من القمه لماذا
لو تداعيات او ابعاد جديده مل الرساله
التي يحاول نمررها
من خلال ذلك نحن نعلم سنوات اعتمد
البرلمان الاوكراني قانونا يعني يسمح لكي
يكون وزير الدفاع هو شخصيه يكون شخصيه
مدنيه وليس عسكريه وبالتالي يعني دور
وزاره الدفاع في الوقت الحالي او وزير
الدفاع هو يعني يعني جلب الدعم والتاييد
لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب العسكريه والحرب
من يجرها الى قياده الاركان وهيئه الاركان
والقاده في وزاره الدفاع يعني وزير الدفاع
الجديد هو اولا مسلم يعني يعكس قضيه جزيره
القرم في البدايه وهذه الرساله هامه رساله
اخرى بان الرئيس يعني اقاله شخصيه كبيره
وهو وزير الدفاع تحت مسمى مكافحه الفساد
وهذا يروق للدول الغربيه والدول المانحه
ثالثه يعني اعتقد ان يعني اميره لديه
افكاره جديده في مواجهه الاحتلال الروسي
لاوكرانيا بشكل عام وجزيره القرم بشكل خاص
كيف حرق على الفساد او قضاء الفساد كيف
على العلاقه مال اتحاد الاوروبي بالنسبه
لعضويه اوكرانيا وايضا مع حلف شمال اطلسيه
يعني الى اي مدى عطلت هذه العمليه قضايا
الفساد بيان حقيقه منذ ان وجهت اوكرانيا
باوصلت نحو اوروبا او الاتحاد الاوروبي
وداعين نقول منذ ثوره الميدان عام
2013 يعني والاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب
الشفافيه ومكافحه الفساد وله مطالب كثيره
مثل تغيير يعني
بعض القوانين في الدستور وفي المحكمه
العليا فبالتالي اعتقد ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يراقب واوكرانيا يعني على قدر
استطاعتها في ظل الامكانياتها الحاليه
تحارب هذا الحساب وتريد ان تلبي المطالب
الغربيه ولكن علينا اننا ننسى ان في كل
دوله لديها يعني مرحله انتقاليه يوجد بها
ما يسمى الحرس القديم
طيب سؤال اخير عن حجم الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا وبعد هذه السلسله من الفضائح
الا ربما
يضع نوع من التشكيك في في هذه المساعدات
خاصه فيما يتعلق برائي العام يعني عندما
تنفجر كل هذه القضايا الفساد داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه وغيرها الا ربما يبعد او يقلل من
الدعم او نيه الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
يعني اعتقد ان هذا موضوع وذاك موضوع يعني
استعمل عسكري لاوكراني اتى على شكل اسلحه
لمواجهه يعني روسيا وتقويه صمود الجيش
الاوكراني امام امام روسيا فبالتالي الغرب
له مصلحه في ذلك في صمود اوكرانيا وفي
استنزاف روسيا فبالتالي اعتقد ان ذلك لن
يؤثر على لم يؤثر من التعب الغربي يعني
هناك اليوم من نتابع ما يحدث من فضائح
داخل المؤسسه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وجيش
يقول بان ربما هذه الاموال وهذا الدعم
الذي يخصص لربما تقويه الجيش والقوات ربما
يذهب الى مكان اخر وبالتالي يؤثر ذلك بشكل
سلبي على التضامن مع اوكرانيا
ولكن ان موضوع الفساد هو موضوع قصه قديمه
في اوكرانيا وليس حديثه فبالتالي اعتقد
انه لن يؤثر بطريقه مباشره لانه الان
مجدرا على دعم اوكرانيا لمواجهه روسيا وا
سوف تحتل اوكرانيا
وقد تاتي الى دول اخرى فبالتالي الغرب
اصبح ايضا مصدر على دعم اوكرانيا وليس منه
عروس تماما شكرا
موقع اوكرانيا اليوم الاخباري كنت معنا من
كيف شكرا جزيلا